that to me the theme of the
anonymization they tell us about the
role of free randomization in TCS
foreign
[Music]
first I'm gonna talk about myself what I
like to think about questions that I
like
then I'm going to share a couple of
interesting tidbits from recent years
results and directions that are
interesting to think of that I want to
focus while I'm here and in the end I
leave some time for questions but as you
can see I have a precise timeline for
each of these parts
okay so uh the randomization just was
still in the same context is usually the
type of thing I'd like to start uh start
from start thinking about and Branch out
from so these are the type of questions
in the area right we use Randomness all
the time in direct computer science but
in many settings it's not really clear
why we do it because I mean we don't
understand whether or not it really
helps make computation more efficient in
a lot of settings so the methodology is
the randomization right let's grab the
random coins and simulate them and the
cost of doing so is the value of
Randomness in this particular setting
this is what KJ talked about and in the
recent Works we're going to show that
under
uh plausible assumptions the value might
be actually zero it makes sense
the second question is how can we do so
how could you how can you randomize
stuff and the classical answer is pseudo
random generators and liger talked about
new non-blackbox approaches which other
methods are there and what can they
teach us about the problem that we don't
know and don't understand yet and to
prove that the methods work we need to
make assumptions the classical ones were
for several and generators for circular
abounds new methods have weaker
assumptions which assumptions are
necessary and sufficient for the
randomization and the third question is
what are the broader implications of
doing the randomization on computer
science
and this is how I look at the world when
I wake up in the morning okay I'm not
saying that this is exactly how the
world looks like but it's my perspective
the animal is actually really at the
heart of computer science right it's
inherently related to any other area
people's NP robots for circuits robot
for Turing machines crypto interactive
proofs meta complexity learning theory
finding anything
and the thing is that I don't have a
good explanation why I mean the
randomization is interesting because
it's an important question we use
Randomness all the time and it's a
challenging question we've been dealing
it for a long time so obviously it's
important and another reason that it's
important is that it's so interconnected
but I don't have a one minute elevator
pitch to explain why it's so
interconnected other than listing to any
technical theorems that explains this
so the usual mode of research in the
area is to start from a question about
Randomness like take a class of
algorithms and try to grab the random
coins and take them away and Branch out
to work in circuit complexity
interactive proof script so extractors
Etc across the Retro computer science so
a couple of other questions that I like
thinking about
so in circuit complexity for example
unconditional dynamization and lower
bounds for threshold circuits is
something that I've been doing in recent
years and for essentially any other
Frontier in circuit complexity that we
all know and work on and more generally
like moving onwards with new approaches
for circuit complexity we know that math
and combinatorics Aren't Enough this is
um okay Ryan gave us new tools the
algorithmic methods so we control the
randomization algorithm design and
interactive proofs cool which other
tools from Theory can we throw at the
problem circuit complexity this is now a
problem in theoretical computer science
we have lots of tools in theory what can
we throw at it and in particular how can
we relax the for example the algorithms
in Ryan's approach to get to still get
circuit overbounds I'm going to talk
about it in a second and more generally
let's call it sharing sharing techniques
between different areas and theoretical
computer science for example can we do a
complexity analysis of crypto Primitives
can we construct randomization
algorithms from proof systems and so on
okay
I want to share a few interesting
tidbits that I think you might be
curious about and that are more an
invitation to think about rather than
the specific results themselves I think
these are areas that are worth exploring
that I'd like to explore while I'm here
these are three specific things
the first one Legion just mentioned it
follows from uh work with us from a
couple of years ago so prgs are
equivalent to Circuit lower bounds and
as we just said okay it's totally
natural to ask great what is the
randomization equivalent to maybe it's
equivalent to something that might be
weaker I need to presenting one
condition from Oracle first this almost
all inputs hardness writers function in
B such that every probabilistically just
said n to the 10 I wrote n to the 20
that's because I'm a more hesitant
person and Legion is more confident so I
wrote 10 to the 20. okay fails to
compute it on all but finitely many
inputs and we show the bi-directional
connection we conjecture it can be
turned into an equivalence okay this
gives one target answer it's actually a
great open problem in case you want to
talk about
but something more interesting happened
later it turns out that the
randomization is actually fully formally
equivalent to a sequence of Notions from
different areas in theoretical computer
science for example in two works of
yaniel and Raphael pass shows that show
that they're equivalent to the almost
all input variant of hardness of
conditional time-bounded complexity you
know flickage resilient hardness from
crypto upcoming work with Legion with
the third co-author who I haven't asked
before the talk so I can't say who is
but we're working on it there's another
notion which substances and the point
isn't that the randomization is
equivalent to Notions from different
areas in TCS is that like trivially now
that we have this all of these Notions
are equivalent to each other
exactly because the hardness of
conditional time-bound number of
complexity is equivalent to leakage
resilience hardness is equivalent to an
ocean from complexity and we don't know
how to prove it without centering the
randomization in this picture
and more importantly I don't think so
it's a new emerging Network and I don't
think we understand it well enough how
crucial is the almost all inputs
condition how deep are the connections
between these different Notions
so there's a function like X to FX
that's hard to compute even with some
leakage from FX but it's hard for every
X
for everything
there are word phenomenons in this new
network of connection for example we
click and transition
smaller kids gives you hardness with
larger treatments
for functions
so that's an invitation to pick because
we don't understand this well enough yet
it's it's also very it's less than your
old
okay another thing I'd like to present
an option that's uh very new it's from a
work with Legion that's under submission
but that's so basically if you have been
taught in complexity one-on-one 101 this
notion and they would have told you that
this is an ocean from the 80s you would
have said sure like of course
so this is computationally sound NP and
we all know MP we'll have NP correct
statements can be proved incorrect
statements cannot be proved wonderful
and we know in love argument systems
from crypto interactive proof or like
you can be convinced but no efficient
adversary can convince you you have only
computational soundness so this is the
computationally sound version of MP
correct statements can be proved
incorrect statements no adversary can
find the written proof and send it to
you there's no interaction so it's an MP
type argument system a very natural
notion
so here's the definition we say that the
language has a doubly efficient sorry
deterministic effective argument system
if there's an NP type verifier
that started advancing the allotted time
and satisfies the following condition
but you can prove correct statements to
it so there's an efficient proofer that
like given a correct statement it prints
a proof sends it to the verifier the
verify says yes but on the other hand
the sound is conditioned is
computational no efficient adversary can
fool the verify except with negligible
probability we're fooling the verify
here means finding an incorrect
statement and the proof that will make
the verify say yes
need to see an original business
ah okay so the I this right now the
definition as it is it's like uh only
for BPP problems right because there are
no weaknesses here but you can equip the
honest proofer with the weakness and you
can equip if you want to this one is
proven with the witness to extend it to
MP this is standard stuff from crypto so
I just wanted to focus on like one
self-contained definition you can extend
it if you want
now that for all three with running time
polynomial sounds
yeah yeah but the definition of the
definition only makes sense if the
honest program is efficient to otherwise
you can trigly get this stuff for
later restrictions
one message
exactly and there's another subtle
figure but it's very natural like
usually in arguments the soundness is
for all this will stay simple but for
every input that you can't produce a
push okay the adversary cannot find an
input on it so it's either choice but I
mean it's very interesting
okay so it's in your natural notion that
computationally sound empty what can you
what can you do with it so we know who
showed we're passing through the
randomization proof sentence and yada
but forget about it this is
self-contained statement under strong
assumptions you can some jumps up too
quickly in computational sound
okay remember we believe that trucks
that cannot be solved by a
non-deterministic machine like an MP
real MP right in time two to the Epsilon
and web services as far as you want but
under a strong assumption in this
computation sound MP you can beat that
you can sell shots that in time to that
synonym is a smallest concept as you
want
and I mean there's no reason to assume
that this is the optimal running time if
we take inspiration from classical
results in crypto like Killian maybe we
can do polynomial time too
like this is a new relaxed notion of NP
that allows bypassing certain
um barriers and obstacles
but again like even for the access even
if I would have made our worst case
statement right for every X this thing
holds it still would have been the case
that for every exponent has been a proof
that this is a very fine you just can
find it in both cases
that they might be building your
incorrect things so that's okay
yeah exactly exactly 100
. what I would say is that the
reason for the computational relaxation
holds for the worst case and for the
average case settings so the same way
that one one thinks it's forever input
you can find the Blue Shield
so feasible word no one can see
okay so computationally sound empty
right totally new we haven't thought
about it for long so it's really open
Can You Solve Sharps that more quickly
which other hard problems can you solve
with it what could you do what in this
new model that people haven't thought of
it's probably an open-ended question
that's really worth pursuing
okay the last thing I want to talk about
has to do with the weak forms of
randomization implies lower bounds or
strong forms because it's weak the
randomization still implies roll balance
so let's uh I'm going to talk about
Quantified randomization let's Zoom back
to Ryan Williams result Ryan told us
that to prove lower bounds it suffices
to fall to solve the following the
randomization problem I give you a
circuit over n Bits and you need to
decide between the case that the circuit
accepts all of its inputs in the case
that the circuit accepts at most half of
its inputs right you need to do it in
non-trivial time so better than two to
the n two to the N over a large enough
polynomial
and I want to introduce notation so that
there's a number of exceptional inputs
here right in the second case the
circuit accepts at most half of its
inputs
so at most two to the N over 2. let's
denote it by B
just a parameter
and of course if I want to distinguish
between a case that the circuit accepts
all of its inputs and the circuits
accepted at most B inputs I can do it in
time B plus 1 times the circuit size
right so just go over more than b inputs
and distinguish between the two cases no
problem
and the rents result from this
perspective tells us that for this value
of B doing so in time better than b b
over polylog
is enough to get circuit lower balance
right this type of problem when you have
this parameter value B it's type of
Quantified problem it's a Quantified
randomization problem
and the point that I want to make in
reframing this is that it turns out that
you can generalize Ryan's results
so there's nothing special about this B
if you can solve this Quantified
randomization problem in time better
than b for any value of B you get
circular balance so for any nice value
like time computable or whatever if you
can distinguish between the case of the
circuit accepts all of its inputs and
the circuit except its most brief inputs
in time better than b then you get lower
bounds and it's the same lower bounds
and the same relaxation as in Rhymes
result it's a black box reduction to
rights result
but the point that I want to make here
is that okay what's going on like it's
not that the randomization was holy like
uh one versus having the acceptance
probability any value would do so what
makes this problem so special
well if you no actually not it works for
polynomial you just have to be careful
you face a problem in terms of b as a
polynomial Enterprise production
minus X you know
moments
I look at this and it starts it gets me
asking questions like okay what's
special about this what kind of weak
algorithms are enough to get circuit
lower bounds like uh the randomization
is sort of a classical thing but if this
wafer thing is enough what are we
missing where can we go next this is
another thing that I have to think about
it and that was it this is the time for
questions thank you very much
any questions and we have the next
speaker set up
that's a nice name for being a fine
computable increasing oh really okay
their analog of Quantified de
randomization in the uniform setting
like a similar kind of relaxation with a
smooth threshold that you can move
around
for uniform circuits
um no no like the the characterization
of next not equals BPT by like the um
very very weak in randomization of BPP
into some exponentials is it is
a great question
foreign
weaker circuit classes the picture
changes it's not like uh any better than
this force will do that oh we can do
this unconditionally and any better than
this one is identical across settings
like every time the threshold the gap
between the normal result and the
threshold result is consistent with
timing and there are so much connections
right thanks a lot